Wanya Morris and Lindsay Arnold serve up  some serious in st. nostalgia on Dancing  with the Stars it's incredible you did  it did the boys to men's singer and his  pro partner absolutely slayed on Mondays  famous dances night recreating in sinks  performance at the 2000s  good thing they killed it because Joey  Fatone and Lance Bass were in the  audience  good job could not be more proud of you  my man the routine received tons of  praise from the judges and a nearly  perfect score of 29 out of 30 after the  show wanye opened up to ET about how  awesome it was to have Joey and Lance  there for them to be an audience  supporting me you know that the energy  level was there you know this is all  about you know energy and on we could  fill it in they told us to go and rock  it so we had no choice but to go out  there and try to make them proud